um even you know there's people that
talk about hitler wanting the tall
you know the blond hair blue eye guys
yeah so if you look at the americans who
uh the um paul hillier says
from from canada he's the defense
minister there paul hillier
paul hillier he said that we were
dealing with the tall whites
he said that oh yeah what does he mean
by tall white what is this tall white
thing well supposedly these
are very um uh very tall
very anglo-looking kind of um
nordic aliens and uh they've been
dealing with them for the last 10 years
i've actually heard of these before and
the current sitting defense minister
of canada he's not no longer he's no
longer he's no longer involved in
politics he's out of politics now that's
why he'll come here and talk about it
was part of the part
part of the project disclosure that came
out and he's the one who said
uh ufos are as real as the planes flying
over your house no doubt about it and
america's been dealing with the tall
whites for the last 10
years and who these tall whites were i'm
like can you say that today
really yeah can you what's this guy's
name his name is
paul hillier can you look at this guy
yeah it's
h-e-l-l-y-e-r
first name paul like a bell iran
says tall white space aliens control
america there you go i ran
holy [ __ ] but this is on forbes
documents leaked by the nsa
whistleblower edward snowden
conclusively proved the united states
has been ruled
by a race of tall white space aliens
who also assisted the rise of nazi
germany
in the 1930s these revelations about our
alien overlords might not cost you any
sleep
but that part but the part that should
concern you
a tad is that the ufo story was just
published
by the fars news agency the english
language news service of iran a nation
that may be very close to acquiring
nuclear weapons
this seems like this being a crazy
conspiracy theory naturally
the russians are behind it the alleged
alien invasion was revealed in an
alleged report by the russia's
fsb spy agency which was found
in controversible proof
that the alien extraterrestrial
intelligence agenda is driving us
domestic and international
international policy and has been doing
so
since at least 1945 says the iranian
news service
oh
i mean well i mean this is hanging out
with that guy though no
no flags ain't no paul hillier snowden
who has been given asylum in russia
leaked documents that are
well snowden what snowden did snowden
say that he's
he actually said that he had like the
most most
insane security clearance in the nsa and
he said
he never saw anything about
extraterrestrials but now this
is saying that he released documents
that talk about extraterrestrials
well i think this goes on too with
snowden right now because he's in russia
so he's trying to make sure he stays in
russia so as soon as he runs out of
information to give them
i got a feeling he'll be back in the u.s
as soon as soon as the russians don't
have any more use for them
so he'll continue to let now again
whether is this real
you know is it something he's just
pumping out sunshine up their ass to
make him feel good about hey
check this out um it's the tall white is
a
this will not be the last time you've
heard of them now i didn't hear they
were running the u.s but it's
interesting that the iranians say that
they are um the iranians have had
many many many ufo uh related incidents
again what there's some that are saying
that the middle east
really has all the information that we
need to figure out where we really came
from but they don't want us to find that
so we keep the wars going on there i
think maybe they just have better drugs
than we do
i mean i don't know or maybe they've
been out of the desert for too long
well you know of course they they sell
more heroin
exactly there yeah absolutely
so maybe that's what's going on at the
end of the day it could be but you know
again when you hear things like the tall
whites
nobody's saying that they're tall white
guys they don't have another name for
them it's that tall white thing and
you get why are they tall they're big
they're big they're supposed to be
bigger than us so you know
they then they aren't flying those ships
because those ships fit small little
little well if you go back and look bob
lazar bob lazar store yeah they said the
cockpit of that ship was like
tiny but he also said there was no
bathroom there was no kitchen right
so they were human yeah that was that
was the big question right
he goes are these today he goes if we
could
put a robot in something and fly
tomorrow she goes we would do that
right we went on a risk lives yeah right
so because i think it takes like even
nine months to get there i think two
the challenges are keeping your bones
hard during that period of time because
the bones get so soft
right right right so you lose bone
density when you're basically that's why
that's why the astronauts they have to
like work out that's exactly you see
that
that they're running treadmill typically
on there
yeah trying to keep the bones hard so um
i think at the end of the day when you
start looking again at the bigger
picture
we would have done that we put aliens or
robots into a craft and sent it
someplace
especially if they were that good so
right i that makes perfect sense like
yeah
it kind of makes more sense because what
would you eat right where would you go
to the bathroom
you know where would you so yeah i
ideally come up with something along
those lines
yeah so and especially if you wanted to
just to make sure that you're listening
we're just trying to keep
tabs on the planet um i was watching a
uh this is kind of getting off on us on
a bigfoot story but i was watching a
story where
all these these uh scientists had gotten
together and they were in
alaska and they were there just to get
some video and these were these were
scientists these weren't you know people
who were doing shows or they weren't
looking to do a movie or
strictly doing doing this for um the
sake of trying to figure out what people
are seeing
and in the show one of the scientists in
the in the field and all of a sudden
sees these lights that pop up above the
trees and so he's trying to see what
they are
while this is going on and he's like i'm
not saying these are ufos at all because
that's not what we're out here to look
at we're out here to look at trying to
find out if bigfoot's real
but what is this thing they were looking
at and they watched it for probably 15
minutes
and it was just funny that they're out
there chasing this this animal around
that they say is alive bigfoot
and that they happen to see one of these
things and of course that same night
they see
what they say is a bigfoot they actually
get it on thermal camera did they really
and they were trying to figure out what
they could just tell it was big
yeah and so they sent it off to a guy
and the guy said dude if you were in
africa i tell you i had a gorilla
that looks just like a gorilla right so
that whole story kind of manifested
itself into again back to the ufo thing
are they here to monitor the planet
because i can't think of why else they
would be here i mean what would be the
fascination
you think the tall whites are bigfoot
i mean i would say no because these are
nordic style but who knows
maybe they're wearing like a ghillie
suit or something a big hairy ghillie
suit
i mean it's just strange to get to think
about that in the bigger picture but
there's so many things that that are
so outside of what we understand yeah
when you talk to somebody who's seen a
bigfoot dude they
they're telling you they saw a bigfoot
i'm not they don't have to believe me
so that story in itself is kind of you
know
unbelievable because we're always told
there's no monsters there's nothing out
there that's going to hurt you
and yet you have these events that take
place the whole ufo thing nobody ever
thought
i can remember back as a kid and people
tell me you're nuts to even follow
this crap it's all a bunch of hooey it's
just not real
and here we are you know 45 years later
on the cusp of finding something out
through the pentagon
what was the guy's name that bought
skinwalker ranch
uh he actually what's up world you just
watched a clip from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly pure
uncut content straight from the jungles
of columbia
if you want to watch the full episode
make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
i